While treating breast cancer with nightly rife programs, I tested positive for some micotoxins
and I'm also detoxified parasites, specifically liver flooks and others I am sure.
I've been running separate rife programs for molds and parasites.
Do you have any specific ones that you would recommend and how often?
Well, I wouldn't spend time running any programs for molds.
So when you're tested for micotoxins, understand that is a toxin that a mold produces and
that you have consumed it or breathed it in.
And now that is an inner toxin, that's not a living organism.
So the programs on the rife for molds and fungus, you really don't need to run unless you
think you have an acute mold, toxin, mold poisoning, living organism, typically you're
going to have one of the issues.
So an acute fungal infection typically is going to be lung issues, breathing issues, then
you can run molds and fungus programs out of the rife.
But if you're going off of, well, I don't have that, I'm doing it because I have a positive
micotoxin test, that's not a mold and fungus.
That is a toxin that a mold produces that you consume somehow.
So there really isn't a rife program to get rid of micotoxins, except doing the footpath
programs with detox and supporting detoxification.
As far as the parasite programs, yeah, if you know the specific parasite that you have,
then you can run that specific parasite program, I don't know what the specific parasite
I have is.
So run the all bugs kill program.
That's my favorite.
The rife is the all bugs kill, there's an overnight all bugs kill if you want to do that,
there's daytime all bugs kill program.
And if you notice that there's stuff coming out of you when you're running a program, then
stay running that program.
So, you know, frequencies are a little equal to that just because we know that this frequency
is tied to this parasite, it can function, it can kill other parasites too.
So, run whatever works for you.